ADAM: Well, I'm
Adam [? Quayo. ?]
thank you very much
for being here.
I'm excited to see a lot
of faces that I do now
and then a lot of faces
that I don't know.
So that's really
good that people are
excited to hear these ideas.
As I introduce Rob, I
wanted to just share
a personal story of how these
powerful ideas have impacted
my life.
So for that I'll use an
example from last year
where I was invited to speak at
an entrepreneurial conference.
And, you know, I kept
putting off and putting off
planning this speech.
It was just a 10-minute talk,
but I was kind of convinced
that I didn't really
have anything to share.
So I just was like, eh, you
know what, I'll just wing it.
And two hours
before my talk, Rob
gets up at the same
conference and shares
some ideas-- some of
which you'll hear today,
many of these have
evolved since then--
but even as I was hearing
him say that we often
sabotage ourselves to
give ourselves an out.
So in this case I
was not planning
so that if I winged it and it
didn't go well I could say,
oh well, I just winged it
and I didn't really plan.
So if I had planned it
would have been great.
So I gave myself that out and
sure enough I went up there,
I winged it, and
it went all right,
but I didn't really crush
it like I would've hoped.
But I winged it, so
what can I expect?
And as people kept coming up to
me and saying, hey, great job.
Loved the talk.
Thank you so much for sharing.
I was like, really?
No way.
That wasn't very good.
I just winged it.
So from the time I finished
my speech until about 10:00
PM that night I just
kept beating myself up.
Just negative self talk.
Man, you're so stupid.
You didn't even plan this talk.
You're up in front all
these people just rambling.
And no matter how many people
kept telling me great job,
I wasn't hearing it.
And then I ran in to
Rob later that night
at the bar for the after
party of this event.
And he again said, great job.
And I said, I don't really know.
I just kind of got up
there and winged it
and I don't think
it went very well.
And he essentially
was like, do you mind
if we do guided meditation?
I was like, well, we're
standing at the bar here
but all right, let's do it.
Why not?
And so he guided me
through a meditation
and he basically created
the space for this idea
that no matter what happens,
whether that speech was great
or that speech was terrible
in any moment we have a choice
to decide is this thought that's
running through my head useful
or not useful?
And if it's not useful, you
can just choose to let it go.
So that's really stuck with me
in this high pressure Google
environment that we all work
in where we're constantly
trying to innovate and
do really cool things.
There's some negative self talk
that comes in for me a lot.
And so now I can just decide
is that useful or not useful.
So that's just one
thing that I wanted
to share because it really made
a huge impact on me and the way
that I look at things.
And so please join me in
welcoming my friend Rob Scott
to the stage and to Google.
Thanks for being here, Rob.
ROB SCOTT: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi, everybody.
How are you guys doing today?
Good?
Doing well?
Awesome.
So this talk is called
"The Fundamental Shift."
And I'm really planning to
give you guys a really, really
tangible fundamental shift.
And the subtitle of this is how
to destroy any limiting belief
and master your mind, which
might sound slightly dramatic.
It's like master your mind.
What is that?
But I'm hoping to make
that really tangible
and give you guys a
profound understanding
of a different way that we
can kind of relate to our mind
and deal with our mind and
really tangible tools that Adam
gave an example of right there.
Before we dive in,
I want to really
kind of get down to the
reality that you guys want
to make a difference, right?
This is your time.
This matters.
And you guys are important
and you're up to cool things.
And so to come spend time,
this should make a difference.
So in that can we set
an intention together
that maybe we open
to the possibility
that this talk could
profoundly change you.
There's a lot of different
things that happen.
There's a lot different
things that we can experience.
We could be wasting time
watching TV or doing whatever.
Some time is more
valuable than other time.
So I want you to open to
the possibility maybe even
in a collective
breath or something
that we could all kind of
set the intention that this
is really profound.
That we actually
do something that's
really meaningful long
term for you guys.
So is that possible?
Think about some other powerful
ideas that changed the game.
Things like the
wheel or figuring out
what your next move is,
where you're going to apply,
or maybe meeting
your partner in life.
Some moments really matter.
And so what if I
could promise you
a shift caused you not only to
become incredibly productive
but also deeply fulfilled
at the same time?
Because we've kind of
got two worlds going on.
We've got the world of being
and experience and sort
of the art of fulfillment.
And then we've got the
doing, the success part.
And they both really matter.
They both really matter.
Tony Robbins or somebody like
that is awesome at success.
And maybe Eckhart Tolle is
really awesome at presence.
We want to master both.
And so for this shift that
we're talking about today
it really does apply
to both of those areas.
And so my intention is to
create that space for that shift
in you guys today.
And minimally I promise that
I'm going to share at least one
incredibly valuable idea
with you today and probably
many of them.
So last little
intro here is I want
you to relax and just trust that
you can get the transmission.
We're really, really
good at communicating.
You don't have to
furiously take notes,
although you may choose
to write some things down.
But just relax into this.
Let's have fun.
Let's enjoy this time and
make it really valuable, OK?
So things that I'm going
to cover today quickly,
I'm going to share a
little bit more about me.
Many of you probably
have no idea who I am.
And so I want to let you
know a little bit about why
I get to come and talk to you.
I'm going to talk
and share with you
through hopefully a
visualization you'll
join me in the cost of
our limiting beliefs.
We're going to talk about
where these beliefs come from,
because it's really important
to understand how insidious
and kind of sneaky they can be.
And I'm going to share with
you some of the reasons why
we can't see them.
How do we get in touch with
them when we don't even
know they're there.
Is it possible you're
carrying a limiting belief
and you don't even
know you have it.
It just feels like
a truth to you.
And then we're going to talk
about the single change that
shifts everything.
Some things you should
take away is really
how to master your beliefs.
After this talk I want you guys
to have access to mastering
your own belief structures.
I want you to understand
this concept of lenses
that I'm going to go
into in depth today.
We're going to talk about a
formula for procrastination.
OK?
There's actually a
formula that kind of
explains why we choose
to procrastinate
or why we feel resistance
when we're trying to do
some important piece of work.
And we're going to get
into impostor syndrome.
I don't know if any of
you ever feel slightly
fraudulent or worried
that maybe they'll
find out that I'm really not as
special as I like to think I am
or that I hope they think I am.
So we're going to talk
about impostor syndrome.
And then other things
like core story,
meaning making, where you get
into it what truth is actually
in this talk.
But the most important takeaway
is the fundamental shift
that changes everything.
So why should you listen to me?
Why would you spend this time?
Well, I'm Rob Scott and
I wish that was enough.
But there's probably
more to it than that.
I went through some really
major abuse as a child.
And not to be overly
graphic or whatever,
but there was a period of
time from like three or four
to about eight or nine where
I was actually being raped
and just really violently
sexually abused, et cetera.
And not only that,
but other dysfunctions
in the family and addiction in
the family and all that stuff.
These things left me scarred
physically, emotionally,
and mentally.
I basically didn't feel safe.
I didn't have a lot
of emotional maturity.
I kind of got stunted in
a lot of ways emotionally
and in other things.
And so I turned to
drugs and alcohol,
starting to play with them
as early as 7-years-old.
And when I had my first
nephew in my life,
when I looked at how
old he was at seven,
and now I have a boy in my
life through my girlfriend
and my partner who's six, it
just kind of blows my mind
that that was what was
going on for me at that age.
And so later that
grew into me being
in and out of institutions and
jails and just a ton of chaos
and I ended up homeless.
I was not able to
deal with life.
So I was horribly dysfunctional.
Like pretty much as bad
as it gets without dying.
I had a lot of people
around me that died,
commit suicide, gun fights, all
kinds of crazy stuff like that.
And so I was living
as a victim and I
was unable to deal
with my own life.
And after all that
was going on and I
began trying to get
my life back together,
I had my next challenge and I
got really sick with cancer.
And so here's a picture of
me going through chemotherapy
and smoking.
And right above that
which is out of frame
is a No Smoking sign.
So that was the kind
of guy that I was.
Right?
I'm rolling my chemo dose
outside to smoke back then.
So that was what was going on.
My mom actually
worked close to where
I was getting this treatment.
And I didn't know
she was walking up
but she came up and just
took a picture of me
and that's what this is.
So I know what it is to
be really sick mentally,
emotionally, and physically.
I'm in touch with that.
And from that abuse and sickness
and homelessness and addiction
and all that stuff,
what happened?
Well I had a profound
shift in awareness.
Somewhere along the way I
really woke up to the victim
that I was doing.
And I realized that nobody
was punching me anymore.
Nobody was doing anything, but
I was carrying a story with me
that was no longer empowering.
It was very, very difficult
to function because poor me.
Look at all I've been through.
And I really woke up to that.
And it was deeply profound.
And a new level of consciousness
became available to me.
I didn't relate to my brain
in the same way again.
And from then just a few short
years I went from being a temp,
like my first attempt to getting
a job after being homeless
was filing papers in the
basement of a company.
And a few years after that
I became the youngest vice
president-- I had moved
companies-- but it
was a different company.
And I was running
technology and building
and I built and
sold a big business
for them, a big software
company, and all that.
And so I learned to
manage myself and others
and started to get really
incredible results.
But I also felt deep
fulfilment and happiness.
There was a being and doing that
was really addressed in this.
So in 2005 I started
a podcast where
I was sharing ideas
about conscious evolution
and what is it, what's
hypnosis, and what's NLP,
and what are all these things
about managing our brain
and getting better results?
And people all over the world
started asking me for coaching.
So Japan and Australia
and Ireland and Canada
and a lot in the United States.
And so about a decade ago
I left the corporate world
to start this company where
I get to help people and help
them get better
results, help them
resolve a lot of inner
conflict, and just grow.
So I know what it
takes to change.
I've done it myself and I've
helped thousands of others
do it, as well.
And what it really takes
is this fundamental shift
that I'm going to be
sharing with you today.
So are you guys ready
to dive in on this?
Do you want to know
more about this?
And does this sound important?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ROB SCOTT: I get
like quiet nods.
That's awesome.
How about a little louder?
Do you want to hear
about this or no?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ROB SCOTT: All right.
Awesome.
So when people hire me, when
people come to work with me,
they often want very
different things.
But there's three or so
flavors of what people want.
First they want often better
stuff to happen in their life.
They want better events.
They want to get the house.
They want to get
the girl or guy.
They want to have the new job.
They want better events
to happen in their world.
The next one is they
want to feel better.
Some people come to me and they
go, I'm anxious all the time.
How can you help me
be more confident?
Or I'm depressed.
I can't figure out
happiness, et cetera.
So there's this focus on state
and how they feel that way.
And then the last one is many
people come and they're like,
I can't stick to my habits
or I can't break this habit.
I want to work out all
the time but I can't.
So they want
different behaviors.
And I just want to show
a little bit of a model
here for you guys
about how this works.
Events happen out there, and of
course we want different ones,
but as events happen
to us they end up
making us feel a certain way.
And so these events lead
to a certain state for us.
Events happen, we
sort of have them,
they make us feel a certain way.
If we feel a certain
way, that affects what?
So events affect our state.
Our state affects our behaviors.
And if I'm confident I'll
take different behaviors
than if I'm anxious
about something
or if I'm fearful,
if I'm depressed.
That's going to change what
I choose to do in the world.
And then our behaviors,
to whatever degree,
affects our events.
It doesn't have total
control over it.
None of these do.
But this is a loop of
how our life goes by.
Events happen.
It creates a certain
feeling in us.
That creates certain behavior.
We get new events.
And that goes on like that.
So let's be clear.
We want all of it.
We actually want better
events to happen in our life.
We also want better
state experiences.
And we also want more
control over our behavior.
And there's one
place on that slide
that we're going to make a
slight addition to later that's
going to be the game changer.
So this slide you'll be
seeing it again later.
And there's one
place where we're
going to make a
big change there,
and I'll share
what that is later.
Before we really get
started, I want to find out
what limiting beliefs cost us.
And I'd like to do that kind
of experientially if that's OK.
So if you guys are
open to it, would you
do a visualization with me?
Yeah?
OK.
Again, really quiet.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ROB SCOTT: Awesome.
Good.
All right.
So get comfortable
in your chair.
And go ahead and just start
to get in touch with like what
your breath feels like.
And I'm going to invite
you all to close your eyes.
And anybody watching
the recording
go ahead and close your
eyes and really get
into this experience.
I want you to notice
your breath as it
goes in and out of your body.
And you may notice
that down in your belly
as you breathe in it's almost
as if a balloon is expanding.
And you can feel that
expand and contract.
You may notice the slight hum
of technology in the room.
You can hear that.
I'm going to invite
you to notice
another part of your breath.
You can maybe notice what
the rim of your nostrils
feels like as you
breathe in and out.
Cool, dry air going in.
Maybe a little bit warm, a
little bit more moist air
leaving.
And I'm going to invite you
to scan your body for anywhere
that feels pleasurable.
Any sensations that
feel comfortable.
I'm noticing what my feet
feel like on the ground.
You may notice your
seat in the chair.
So this is presence.
There's not really
any thought here.
This is just experience.
And this is a fantastic place
to get really grounded into
and know about.
But now we're going to actually
start to use our imagination.
So keep your eyes
closed, but I want
you to imagine a person maybe
down in a way and kind of
off to the left so you
could see over their life.
And this person is a lot
like you but they're not you.
But they have goals
like you have.
They want to be successful.
They want to be loved.
They want to have friendships.
See this person
going through life
trying to achieve all the things
that they're trying to achieve.
Have the connections that
they're trying to have.
And yet they walk through
life thinking these kinds
of thoughts about themselves.
They say, I have no energy.
I hate my body.
I'm fat and I'm ugly.
I'm too lazy.
People don't really like me.
I'm not lovable.
I'm not approachable.
I'm kind of nerdy.
Nobody really gets me.
See them trying to shake
hands, meet people,
forward their initiatives
what they want to do.
And yet they say things
in their head, you know,
I already have enough.
I shouldn't want anymore.
I'm not really very smart.
I'm certainly not as smart
as people think I am.
What if they find out that
I'm not what I say I am?
I'll never be rich.
I'll never have enough time.
I'm always late.
I'm going to mess this up.
Nothing I do matters.
I'm just not enough.
Get really in touch
with this person.
Up late at night worried
about their life.
Worried about different things.
Trying to go to sleep and
those thoughts creep in again.
My family doesn't
really love me.
I'm never really happy.
I kind of don't
know what that is.
The world is scary
and dangerous.
I'm kind of a loser.
This isn't really going
to work out for me.
I want you to keep
your eyes closed,
but you can answer out loud
if it makes sense to you.
How's that person going to
do with their goals in life?
Are they going to do really
well or are they going to
do not so well?
Go ahead and answer out loud.
Are they going to
do not so well?
They're not going
to do very well.
It's almost like they're
carrying a huge albatross.
They're just weighed
down like they've
got a weight on their
ankle carrying them down.
So I want you to now
imagine another person.
Maybe they're down and
away off to the right
and you can see them.
And this person
has no advantages
over the first person.
They don't have
more connections.
They don't have any more money.
They don't have any
more intelligence.
In fact, they're
not even as smart.
They don't have as many friends.
Their style isn't even as good.
They don't dress as well.
And they have similar goals.
They want to be successful.
They want to be loved.
They want all these things.
And the difference between this
person and the first person
is that their brain
is saying things
like this-- I love what I do.
I'm really, really
good at my job.
My mind is incredible.
I can't believe
how well it works.
I love learning and growing.
I love making and saving money.
I feel so grateful and happy.
I love my body.
How it takes care of me.
See this person meeting
people, deciding to work,
deciding to show up,
deciding to apply themselves
to different things.
See them bebopping along going
I feel like I'm in my purpose.
I love focusing on
what matters most.
I get great results.
I make a difference.
I love how much energy I have.
I am enough.
I am amazing.
I love meeting people.
I feel so grateful, happy.
I'm enough.
I get great results.
How is this person going to do?
Go ahead and answer out loud.
Are they going to do OK or are
they going to be struggling?
They're going to be doing
really, really well.
And I want you to
notice while you're
thinking about this
person that they're not
going to be successful
in the future,
this is an expression
of success now
with all the disadvantages
without everything.
Hold in your mind for
a second the difference
between those two people.
And I want you to just
breathe into that difference
and when you feel comfortable
you can open up your eyes
and join us back here.
So are we clear on the cost
of what our thought is?
Do you guys feel the
difference in that?
Can you feel that the
invitation of even
a single negative thought
can make us not do something?
It can cost us
quite a bit, yeah?
And these beliefs don't
have to be 100% true.
We're not talking
about somebody who
is that kind of stuck in it.
Imagine just going to a party
with the simple difference
of in one moment feeling
really connected,
like I can't wait
to be in this party.
Oh my god, all these people
are my close friends.
This is going to be so much fun.
Versus having a different
thought of I feel separate.
I don't feel connected.
This isn't my tribe.
I don't like them.
This party's going
to suck or whatever.
One person's going to actually
see a different party.
Same party.
One person who's connected
and looking for it
is going to be super thrilled.
How you doing?
Oh my god.
What's going on?
Hey.
It's good to see you.
Right?
Somebody else is going
to be kind of inviting
this negative thing.
Can you guys feel the
difference between that?
That just that in any
moment our thoughts
have that kind of control over
what's going to happen for us.
So let's go over a couple
ways we can pick up these
limiting beliefs in our life.
I want to introduce an idea
called your core story.
A friend and mentor of
mine, [? Mark Ofney, ?]
calls this your core sentence.
And what I want you to do is
I want you to imagine yourself
as a baby.
All right?
And you don't have a
huge sense of self yet.
You're still
completely dependent
on your primary caregivers.
And you're there.
And every time you
cry, you're met
with a bottle or
your wiped clean,
or you're sort of
doted on and dealt
with until there was a
first time where maybe
your mom was busy doing dishes
or didn't hear you or whatever.
There's a first time that your
primary caregiver didn't come.
And when that happens
there's a bit of a crisis.
There's this kind of, oh no.
What happened here?
And so that first
hurt led to a meaning.
And ultimately it's
really hard to blame
the all powerful caregiver.
It's very hard to say this
all powerful godlike creature
that's giving me all
my needs meeting those
that there's some flaw there.
There can't be something
wrong with the universe
or it's just too unsafe.
So there must be
something wrong with me.
Right?
There must be something
wrong with me.
And so we end up making
a meaning out of that.
And some possible meanings
that we can start to grab onto
are maybe I don't deserve love.
Maybe in this moment
I don't deserve love.
Maybe I didn't do right or I was
too loud or I was too annoying.
Maybe I'm too much
for my mother.
Maybe nobody loves me.
Maybe love isn't
real or permanent.
Maybe the world's
just dangerous.
And my personal favorite
is I'm not enough.
Maybe I'm just not enough.
Maybe I am not enough.
So when that becomes true for us
as a small child, what ends up
happening is we grow
up continually looking
for examples of that truth.
That truth made sense out
of something in the moment,
so it becomes what
we think is real.
And so we end up seeing not
enough kind of everywhere.
If I'm not enough, well,
I don't have enough time.
I don't have enough money.
There's all these examples
of where that shows up,
this not enough.
I'm not popular enough.
I'm not funny enough.
I'm not pretty enough.
My car's not enough.
Et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
It becomes this prism
that we look through kind
of at the whole world.
And that's because
this truth made
us feel safe in the moment.
It's how the world made
sense to us at one point, OK?
So we actually live
into that belief.
And if you think about that
in any way, maybe some of you
can identify with this
sense of I'm not enough.
I'm not smart enough.
I'm not standing out enough.
I'm not really where
I'm supposed to be yet.
So this belief is
potentially I'm not enough,
but it could be any of
those other ones, as well.
Can you see how subtle
and non-obvious this is?
It's from the very
beginning of our narrative
potentially of growing up.
And it just becomes
kind of true.
It's like we have this
facade of I'm totally enough.
Yeah, sure.
I got it.
We're cool.
But down deep I'm
worried about it
because maybe I'm not enough.
So I want to quickly
look at another example.
And this is really the
formula for procrastination.
And if you're not taking
notes, that's great.
I'm not inviting
you to, but this
might be something cool to just
make a note of in your head.
The formula is this.
Self worth equals ability
which equals performance.
And for this I
want you to imagine
that you are potentially
a hunter 10,000 years ago.
And you eat a lot as a hunter
but you're not performing.
You're not actually bringing
back food to the tribe.
So you're doing your best,
but it's just not working out.
All of a sudden your lack of
performance might be fatal.
They might say,
hey, stop eating.
You're eating too much.
You're not bringing
in enough food here.
Or they might actually
leave you or whatever.
So it's possible that
in our DNA in our way
we have this ability to
really connect with this idea
that my self worth, my
value as a human being,
is proven by my
ability at things.
And my ability is proven
by my performance.
Does that makes sense?
Like I may not really be
worthy as a human being
to be taking up the resources
or doing whatever if I don't
perform exceptionally well.
If I can't perform fantastic.
Well, what procrastination
does-- procrastination is not
like a problem in your mind.
It actually gives us an excuse.
It actually kind of
breaks this formula
because the cost of performing
becomes very, very high.
And if I can avoid performance
when these kinds of things
are true for me, if I
can avoid performance
I can keep a story of a
really high self worth.
I can keep a story of I matter.
Man, me and my
potential is amazing.
So what do we do?
We stay disorganized.
Or we leave certain
things unattended to.
Or we just don't show up.
Or, in Adam's case, we
don't prepare the talk.
So that unconsciously
or subconsciously
we can show up
with the excuse of,
you know what, if
I'd really studied,
I would have done fantastic.
I would've done amazing.
But because I didn't
study I got a 78 on that.
So that's OK, because there's
a version of me that could
have shown up and been amazing.
But if I really do try as hard
as I can or I really do show up
and then I fail, than
I'm really not worthy.
And this comes up in subtle
ways across all kinds of things.
When we have parents that
are like, did you get an A?
Oh, you got a B.
Did you get an A?
Awesome.
Did you get the best score?
Oh.
Somebody else in your
class is ahead of you?
All right.
Well, try harder next time.
So our worth is equated
to our performance.
And it puts a huge amount
of pressure on performing.
So what procrastination
does is it
allows us to have a fully
worthy version of ourselves
in our psyche.
And this unchecked can
lead to impostor syndrome.
It can lead to a
whole lot of fakery
in certain situations
about who you really are.
And we end up hiding
in all kinds of ways.
And one of my stories
about this is Fonzie Cool.
I had this idea of growing up
that Fonzie was super duper
cool.
And I don't know if
you guys remember,
but he used to bang the
jukebox and it would turn on.
And he would hit the
lights like that.
And when he danced he just
did this and girls kind of
circled around like magically.
And I grew up as a TV baby
watching Fonzie and going
like, he's got it amazing.
Look at this guy.
He's the jam.
And so me feeling so much shame,
so much embarrassment about who
I really was, I
developed-- and not
consciously, I'm
a kid doing this,
this was kind of like
the game I played--
I developed this bravado
of I'm Fonzie Cool.
Nothing gets to me.
We'll do whatever
you want to do.
Let's do it.
I don't rattle.
I'm good to go.
I can do anything.
And in a lot of ways
that got me in to really
dangerous situations
because I would go do crazy
stuff to be Fonzie Cool.
But also it really held me back
from doing things like this.
I used to be absolutely
phobic-- not just afraid,
not just anxious--
but completely phobic
about giving a public talk.
Now why is that?
Because I had an unconscious
impostor syndrome going
on where if you'd asked me I
would've earnestly told you
I am this cool.
I am Fonzie.
Like, that's going on.
But in reality I
was not that at all.
And what would happen
when I would come up
to give a speech was
my hand might shake
or my voice might shake.
And the mere
possibility that people
could look through that to see
that it might really be true
that I'm worthless and not
this kind of magical cool guy,
I couldn't resolve it.
And so for years-- like
I didn't go to college
because of this stuff.
I'm like, do they
have to give talks?
Oh, they do.
I can't do that and I'm out.
So think about the limits that
that would put on someone if it
wasn't addressed or dealt with.
So another possible belief--
and these are just two,
one is I'm not enougg-- this
one is my value is directly
linked to my performance.
But I have news for you.
That formula is bullshit
because our self worth
should be inherent.
And to a child that is
loved differently or made
to feel more safe,
what ends up happening
for them is that if they
need to go give a talk
it's just something they
do even if they're nervous.
It's like, sure I was
nervous, because there's
no kind of attack on
their identity about that.
Right?
I used to do things,
like an example
I always use is bowling.
I would be invited
to go bowling.
And I'd be like, sure,
it'll be my first time.
But I would go
practice privately so
that I would be amazing or
amazing for the first time.
Whatever I could do
in the three days.
And then I'd show
up and pretend.
Total imposter, be completely
inauthentic about that I'd
been playing for
three days, hoping
that the people at
bowling alley wouldn't
be like, good to see you again.
And then I'd go just so that I
could have that effective of,
isn't he amazing?
Look at how exceptional
this guy is.
I really needed to be
exceptional because who I was
wasn't OK with me.
Now somebody who is
much more well adjusted
than that shows up and
if they bowl a 27 it's
just like I bowled a 27,
because they are actually OK.
They don't hold this
belief necessarily
that my performance defines
my worth as who I am.
So you guys get that?
And this is
underneath the scenes.
You could have listened to
that first visualization
and thought to yourself
none of this is really me.
I don't do these things.
It's not going on like that.
But so much of this is
happening in the background
and we can't even really see it.
So where does inherent
self worth come from?
Well, obviously maybe a
safer environment growing up,
maybe good parents,
maybe, maybe, maybe.
It certainly comes
from our core story.
If I've got a core
story of I'm not
enough it's going to
be difficult to feel
really good about myself.
It also comes from
our meaning making.
And we're going to
talk about meaning
making in just a little bit.
And it basically comes from
our beliefs about ourself.
What do we really truly believe
about who we are and how
can we make who we are really,
really amazing exactly as we
are, wherever we're kind
of coming in on the thing
so that we can actually show
up to do the things that feel
most important to us.
So, again, you may be
thinking this isn't really me.
I don't have these issues.
But they may be more
pervasive than you think.
And so I want to introduce
another idea to you guys.
I'm going to suggest that we've
actually been bred to believe.
And I'm going to share a
story that I originally
from Michael Shermer.
I want you to imagine
you're that hunter 1,000
years ago or 10,000
years ago or whatever.
And you've actually this time
got a kill on your shoulder.
And you have the food with you
and you're going down a path.
And on the right is
like a shear wall.
There's some cliff going up.
So you can't go that way.
And you're on a path.
And all you have is
this field of grass
over here on your left.
And all of a sudden you
hear a rustle in the grass.
And you wondered to yourself,
that could be a tiger
or that might just be the wind.
So is it a tiger
or is it the wind?
Not sure.
Well, it's a long
way back to camp.
I got food here.
Kind of important I
go deal with this.
And around the mountain
has got costs to it.
There's basically two
ways to be wrong here.
I can go the long way and it
was just wind and I overreacted.
Or I can go the short
way and it be the tiger
and I'm wrong that way.
There's two ways
to be wrong here.
You get it?
But one error costs a whole
lot more than the other error.
So one way I might hurt myself.
The food might go bad.
I might run into other trouble.
Whatever.
But if I'm wrong that
way I ran from wind
and probably I get back
and probably I keep living
and probably I continue
to procreate and do
whatever I'm doing.
But the other way
you lose your life.
It's like, if I
thought it was wind
and it was really a saber
tooth tiger and I get eaten up,
I kind of end right there.
So think about that.
Not only do my genes
not get forwarded,
but the memes-- my mental genes,
my teachings, my way of being,
my thoughts about the
world, my belief structure,
maybe any confidence that I had.
So it was incredibly safe.
And over and over and over
again in examples like this
the ones who were
worried made it home.
They made it home.
They didn't take that risk.
And this is prevalent today.
I'm living outside Detroit right
now in Birmingham, Michigan,
but I'm from Philadelphia.
And I used to see old lady
hooligans, which are really
just people coming
back with a basketball
or something like
that, and she would
go the long way like over
here and then she'd get home
and then she'd tell the story
of how she almost got killed.
It almost happened again.
And really she could
have done that 100 times
and had nothing happened.
But it's probably slightly
safer and she's certainly
forwarding her genes and her
memes by doing that move.
So it was safe to believe
the fear, for sure.
And we are the offspring
of that process.
Can we all get on
board with that?
And this works incredibly
well for survival.
I'm curious.
Does anyone here know
when the first year
was that human beings
reached a billion
in population on planet Earth?
I'll just let that hang and if
there's not any quick answers.
When was it?
AUDIENCE: 1900?
ROB SCOTT: Yeah.
It's a little
earlier, but not much.
So it was 1804 actually
that it was the first time.
And I'm shocked that you
were that close really.
Because to me I wouldn't
have guessed that at all.
It feels like it had
to be longer than that.
But it's been about
200 years since then
and now we're about seven
times more than that.
And the only reason
I bring that up
is that survival is
not the problem anymore
in the same way.
We don't have that
problem in the same way.
So we do have beliefs though.
We do have these kind
of demons of fear
and different ways
of looking at things.
And this leads to wars and
all kinds of other stuff.
I would suggest that
understanding our beliefs
is a much bigger problem now.
So how often are we believing?
Because people might go
well, I hold some beliefs.
I have my religious beliefs and
I've got this kind of belief
and I've got that kind
of belief going on.
And we're talking about
limiting beliefs especially.
Those are the ones that we'd
really like to get out of here.
But let's look at
beliefs in general.
How often are we believing?
So I'll tell you a story
so we can try and put
some gumption around this.
I want you to
imagine two really,
really attractive goldfish.
And they're enjoying the pond.
And they're cruising around
all sassy and enjoying the day
and it's like, ho-hum,
ho-hum, what's up.
How you doing?
And an older, wiser fish
swims by and asks, hey guys,
how's the water?
And two younger fish
look at each other
confused for a second and they
go, what the fuck is water?
What's he talking about water?
What is water?
So the idea here is that
the fish can't see the water
because it's their everything.
I haven't been a fish.
They might see water.
They might be like,
that's air up there.
This is water.
Whatever.
However, for this we're
going to kind of get
the idea that they're
swimming in the water.
So it's their whole reality.
So they have no context
of what water is or isn't.
Right?
It's their whole reality.
Well, there's something
that we can't see, as well.
Something that we're swimming
in constantly they we're
not really awake to.
And that is meaning.
We are constantly making up
meaning as we go through life.
We're literally
swimming in meaning.
So my boss looked at me funny,
that means she doesn't like me.
I see horrible
things on the news,
that means the world is unsafe.
The new hot shot got hired.
That means I'm going
to be forgotten.
At our current level
of consciousness,
we make up meaning constantly.
It's actually like the
world that you're living in
is a construction
of your meaning.
So you're believing
all the time.
It's not just the
occasional limiting belief,
although I could probably
find 10 hot buttons or three
hot buttons for any one of you
and make a profound difference
in your life.
But there's an engine
of belief making,
of meaning making,
happening all the time.
And we do it unconsciously.
And sadly often we
do it negatively.
Your meaning in any
moment is your belief.
Now, why is that?
Why am I so sure that
I could say that?
Because the meaning
of belief is this--
it's an assuredness of meaning.
My boss looked at
me with funny eyes,
I know she doesn't like me.
I know it.
It's what it means.
I'm believing that
in that moment.
And the meaning that you create
creates absolutely everything
in your life.
Creates whether
you think you can
have a certain success
along this line
or whether you can
build a big business
or whether you can do whatever.
The meaning you create, if you
keep carrying, I'm not enough,
if you keep carrying,
people don't like me,
if you keep carrying
I'm not attractive,
that's going to affect
to a great degree
everything in your life.
Meaning creates
your very identity,
who you think you are.
Your story of yourself.
So looking at it in
that light, shouldn't we
learn to master our meaning?
Wouldn't it be helpful if
we could master our meaning?
I'm going to teach you
another little idea here.
I want to go into
belief as an error.
So I'm just saying it's kind
of like all belief pretty much.
We're making up meaning
all of the time.
And then I'm going to
call that an error.
And I'm going to mean
it really sincerely.
I want to talk
about three things.
I want to talk about
truth, opinion, and belief.
If we could just kind of slice
up the world into some chunks
here, OK?
Truth.
I'm going to hope
that you can agree
with me that truth is weird.
We think we kind of
have access to truth,
but this has really become
a philosophical debate
on what is true.
And there's always
this kind of parachute
out of the conversation if
philosophers got together
about this.
Well, all of this
could just be a dream.
We could wake up in
some other reality.
And that might be true.
That's great.
But if we really start
to chunk it down,
there is certainly
the difference
between subjective truth
and objective truth.
There's a useful truth
that we can agree on
at like what time it
is and what happened,
but as soon as something happens
and it goes back in the past,
it sort of gets further
from us, and then we
need to depend on
stories about it.
And if we think about
how history is written,
usually the winners
are writing it.
And so what really
happened we don't always
have great access to that.
And subjectively I
would say that it's
very true to kind of be
in touch in the moment
with how you feel, but, again,
as soon as you report on
that then it becomes a history.
And the truth of it
kind of goes away
and it needs to turn into
a story of some sort.
And then there's
the amount of truth.
If we say this is happening,
like my truth is all you
guys now, your truth is
me, not the same thing,
but we would all say it
happened and it was true.
So let's just agree that there
are absolutely useful truths
and there are some
maybe absolute truths,
but truth is weird.
And it's a lot harder to kind of
get our finger on than maybe we
thought about before this.
If that's not clear, I could go
deeper into that, but trust me,
truth is weird.
It's very hard because we're
perceiving and our perception
kind of effects truth.
And so there's a
weird dance there
that we're not
totally in control of.
Then there's opinion.
Opinion is pretty awesome.
Opinion is pretty healthy.
Imagine I'm one of the first
people and I'm walking around
and there's a tree and I bump
into the tree and it really,
really hurts.
Totally healthy for
me to have the opinion
that bumping into
the tree was bad.
And I can say that's my thing.
And these lead to cultures.
Opinions are our own
special preference.
It's some of the stuff
that I want to know
about you if I get to know you.
Or what are your opinions?
How do you see the world?
What's happening?
So opinions seem
very, very safe,
but when we start
to take opinions
too far-- when that guy who
bumped the tree goes back
to his village and starts going,
bumping trees is bad and so
we're not going to
ever bump trees.
And that goes even
further to the point
that anybody who bumps
trees is a lunatic
and we need to kill
them on some level.
Until that guy's walking and
he finds the other place that
bumped into trees and
found the value out
of training by kicking
trees and they're all strong
and now we have a war.
It's like bumping trees is bad.
Kicking trees is amazing.
What are you talking about?
And now we're literally
like firing, right?
Now, what happened there?
It's no longer an opinion.
It's no longer
something I'm holding
that's a preference
of mine or something
that I think is smart but I'm
open to another discussion,
it has solidified into a belief,
an assuredness of meaning.
Kicking trees is lunacy.
What are you doing?
Please cut it out immediately.
Nobody should do that.
And so what happens
is that opinions
start to move toward
feeling like truth.
They start to cruise
over and all of a sudden
they get kind of overtaken
mixed with all that.
And all of a sudden the
opinion part goes away
and all we have is a
big, healthy belief
that feels like truth.
And don't mistake it, our
believes feel like truth to us.
A lot of times we talk about
religious beliefs and things
like that and it's something
we're consciously choosing
and we know it's a belief.
But most of the meaning
making that we're doing
is an assuredness of meaning.
And it's important
that we do that
or we'd be walking around
kind of doubting everything
and it'd be very difficult.
Like we've got to kind of ground
in this.
So just be clear, our
beliefs feel true to us.
I've had clients come to
me and they say, no, Rob,
I am a loser.
You don't understand.
I lost this.
I lost that.
I lost all my money.
I lost the girl.
I lost da, da, da,
da, da, da, da.
And I'm like great, I don't
care at all about any of that
because even if you
have evidence of it,
it's not useful.
It's not useful.
And if you plan to change,
we better put down you
holding on to this
idea of that truth
because it's not really true.
Not if you're capable of change.
It's not an absolute
permanent thing.
It's just been your experience.
But because you're
making it your story,
it's becoming more true for you.
So our beliefs feel true to us.
So remember they're an
assuredness of meaning
and that the error here
is that we're treating
an opinion like a truth.
We've lost access to
knowing which is an opinion
and which is a truth.
This is actually
dangerous and delusional.
Every war that's
ever been fought,
every punch that's ever been
thrown has been over a belief.
It's been an
attachment of meaning
that my way is the
right way and then
I have to go hurt you about it.
So in the same breath
that I say that, beliefs
themselves aren't the problem
because we make meaning
and we have beliefs
kind of all the time.
The problem is being
unaware of our beliefs.
The problem is that we can't
see that we're carrying them,
so they've kind of
stopped into truth.
So maybe it'd be
more true for me
to say opinions, even strong
opinions, aren't the problem,
but as soon as we start
making that error of belief
we have an issue.
So mastery of our beliefs
of our meaning making
is actually the solution.
If we can master this meaning
making, become aware of it
in a different way, we have
a total different access
to things.
So how do we fix this?
We fix this by understanding
an idea about lenses, just
simple lenses.
And I see a bunch of
people wearing glasses.
Some of you might
have contact lenses.
If you haven't had
experience with those,
you've certainly looked through
a microscope or a telescope.
And I want to ask you, what is
the main function of a lens?
AUDIENCE: Distort reality.
ROB SCOTT: Right.
It's to alter what we see.
And it might make it more clear.
It might make it closer up.
It might make it blurry.
But the literal function of a
lense is to alter what we see.
It's what it's built for.
But there's another
function of a lense
that we often don't think about.
And it's not just in
our awareness at all.
It's that lenses are
built to be invisible.
Lenses themself don't
function as well
if I have raindrops on my
glasses or scratches on them,
or if I even just take
them off and consider them
they don't work as well.
They're built to be
looked through so
that I can get into the
altering of whatever I'm
supposed to see through them.
So lenses they alter and
they're built to be invisible
themselves.
Well, our thoughts and
our beliefs are lenses.
I want you to just
grab that for a second.
Our thoughts and our
belief are simply lenses.
And like any good lenses,
they're built to be invisible.
And these lenses alter the
meaning of the world to us.
So whatever lenses
we're carrying.
If you had the parental you're
horrible, you're horrible,
you're horrible, you may
get the I'm horrible lense
and your life will be dealing
with the I'm horrible lense.
If you suddenly had friends
that were different and cool
than you in some way and they
had hurtful things or somebody
called you fat once
when you were younger,
you start to get that lense.
And so we start to see the
whole world through that lense.
Just like our core
story, we can stack
tons of these on top of each
other and make up, what?
Make up our identity.
So think about this.
Think about like a die
hard Republican over here
who's like, those
people are crazy.
What are they thinking?
And then you have the die
hard Democrat over here
who are sure that they're right.
They literally can't understand
how the other one can see it
differently.
Well, what's different?
They're looking through
different lenses.
They're just simply looking
through different lenses.
So pro-choice versus pro-life.
Different lenses.
Omnivore versus vegan.
Christianity versus
Islam versus Judaism.
Different lenses.
Where did we get them?
Our parents.
Our culture.
What our friends think.
This makes up our lenses.
And as we stack up these
different lenses in our life,
they make up our whole
meaning, our whole everything,
in fact our whole self
concept about who we are
and what's possible for us.
What we can do.
What we can and
can't do, et cetera.
And so as we stack
all these lenses,
all these different ways of
seeing ourselves and seeing
others.
Those purple people are bad
and yellow people are good
and mauve people
are whatever, how
clearly are we seeing when
we're kind of stacking up all
these different views on life?
We're not really
looking at truth.
We're looking
through these lenses.
So the fundamental shift
that I promised you guys.
This is what I want
to offer you guys
as a shortcut to getting
to the next level
in your own life in some way.
Instead of blindly looking
through our lenses,
instead of just going
through all those lenses
and being unaware of it because
we're not even aware that we're
doing it most of the time,
we need to actually--
and here's the
fundamental shift--
we need to shift from
looking through our lenses
to move the frame
of our awareness
back to see our
lenses, to actually
consider how am I seeing.
So it's an invitation to go,
I feel like this is true,
but how can I investigate
the truth of it
by looking at how I'm seeing.
Because without this
awareness our limits
seem like truth to us.
They just seem factual.
I am a loser.
This will never work out.
I'll never get that job.
She will never date me.
He will never date me.
This will never work out.
People don't really like me.
I'm unattractive.
They feel like true to us unless
we investigate them and look
and go, what am I
looking through here.
I'm here to tell you that
your mind is lying to you.
It's making up
meaning constantly
and it's making up meaning
that at one time probably
kept you safe and was
useful in that moment,
but then you built
a story around it
and you carried it
further and it has created
the limits of your life.
And your limits
might be really high.
You guys might be incredible.
Huge houses and all that.
But why not even more?
Why not even bigger?
Why is that the
level of comfort?
Why is wherever you
are in the company
kind of where you landed?
Because of your self identity.
It's because of your lenses.
So if you remember
this slide I told
that there was going
to be one place that
was going to change the game.
Right here is where we
make a fundamental shift.
Right here is where we start
to become aware of our lenses.
And so these events
that come in, instead
of just not changing how
we see and just like work,
work, work, work to
get different events,
how can we actually
really become
elevated in how we
understand how we're seeing?
So events come in and we
can now master our meaning
making to a great degree.
And as we do that, we can affect
the states that we experience.
As we affect the states
that we experience,
that influences our behavior.
As our behavior changes,
our events change.
And then we can do this.
And this is a virtuous cycle
that stars to exponentially
grow as we do this.
It's not just one change.
It can become a way to
change iteratively over time.
So ultimately we want
to master our meaning.
We want to become
aware that we're
playing this game
of meaning creation
and start to be able
to edit our thoughts.
Start to check in-- is
that thought helpful to me,
or is it holding me
back in some way?
Instead of just
believing the thought,
we can actually begin
to edit our thoughts.
So to do this we need
to actually begin
to challenge our
interpretations, our truths.
We need to actually challenge
the things that come up
for us, because
if we don't, we're
believing a very biased,
fear-based machine that's
doing great at survival.
You can keep your small
house and keep your limits
and not talk to them and do all
this stuff and you'll survive.
You'll even procreate maybe and
do whatever you do that way,
but you may not thrive
in the same way.
So sadly that's what
most of us are stuck in.
Most of us are blind to this.
We're stuck in our own limits.
We don't know how
to get out of that.
So the power of this
begins to fix the world
because it removes this
delusion that leaders
of state and leaders of
companies and all that stuff
suffer.
So we actually evolve
our consciousness.
This is actually an evolution
in our consciousness.
So I realize we're
coming up on time.
I'm going to speed
up a little bit here.
Are you guys interested in
a simple three-step system
to tangibly do this?
Does this make sense to you?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ROB SCOTT: Awesome.
So really, really fast.
LCR-- Look, Challenge,
and Replace.
Step one is to look.
If you were to actually sit
down and do this with me,
we would actually sit
down and go-- put down
that it's 100% true,
but just write down
any kind of negative
thoughts that you have.
Like give me a list of them.
Well, I'm not really this.
And it takes honesty and it
takes really looking at stuff
that we would normally
bounce off of and not
want to deal with, but
you find your limits.
And, again, we can do
this in a big process
or you can do it
as you see them.
If you learn how to do this,
you can just do it, you see one,
and you can switch it.
If I go to the party
and I feel separate,
I can go, wait, how about I just
connect with how connected I
am to all of these people.
Even if it's just
because you're human.
Or maybe it's because
we're all at Google.
Or maybe it's because whatever,
just that change in that moment
changes the game.
Awareness itself is curative.
If we become aware of it, it
can't affect us negatively
without us seeing it.
So step one by itself
can be largely curative.
Step two is once you know
the negative thought that's
going on-- and, again,
this could be in a process
where you're dealing
with a lot of them
and making a huge change, or it
could be as they kind of occur
to you-- challenge it.
Challenge the story.
Decide to debate it.
I'm not good at this, just
go, maybe I'm good at this.
This won't work out.
Maybe this will work out.
It's literally as
simple as that.
It's having the awareness to go,
what am I thinking right now?
Is that useful?
And is there a better
thought I could be having?
Simply try the opposite idea.
Now there is subtlety to this,
and when I work with people--
it's not like I
am a millionaire.
I am a million.
That's not useful.
You're subconscious is
going to go, no you're not.
What are you talking about?
But I love growing my money.
Really useful.
Instead of, I never have
money, or this won't work out.
So last one is to replace.
So obviously we're
going to challenge it
and then is there
a positive thing
we could actually anchor in?
Again, simply moving
your focus in the moment
is massively effective for this.
But we can also
place new truths.
This is what I do
working with clients.
There's a way to kind of get
these into your subconscious.
If you have I'm not good
enough, we can actually
kind of re-pattern that.
We can re-pattern
your subconscious
with fundamentally more useful,
helpful ideas about yourself
and about the world.
So it's as simple as LCR.
Look-- take the time to
look at what you're doing.
Challenge it.
That's not true.
Wait a second.
Let me look at that.
That's not useful.
And then replace it.
Put something in that's good.
I can kind of
cruise through here
because I know we're
sort of at time,
but there are other paths
as well that can do this.
Any awareness practice
will be beneficial here.
Why?
Because we're starting
to play with thoughts.
We're starting to watch am
I attached to the thought
and caught, or can I abandon
the thought and come back.
Can I drop it and come back.
The benefits of
meditation are many.
In the interest of time
I won't go into this,
but almost anything
valuable in your life
involves delaying gratification.
Having the willpower to
not be instantly like,
I'm just going to
have the sugar,
or I'm going to drink the drink
because I can't control myself,
or I'm going to go touch
that because she's pretty,
or whatever.
We got to slow it
down a little bit.
And every time we delay
gratification, instead of sugar
you eat broccoli,
longer term in your life
it starts looking
much better for you.
Instead of spending
your check every time
you get it, if you invest it, it
starts looking better for you.
And so there's this quality
of delayed gratification
that if you start an
awareness practice
and work with your
mind, what ends up
happening for you is you
actually strengthen the part.
Because every time
you put down a thought
and come back-- because
the instant gratification
is following the thought.
The instant gratification
is going with it.
And if you drop it and come
back to presence or your breath,
you're doing a rep.
You're doing a muscle.
Literally they've shown
strengthening the mind so
that everywhere else in
your life it becomes easier
to delay gratification and stay
wise, stay on the path of what
you really do want
to do and what
you don't want to do
instead of being impulsive.
So this hugely and quickly
helps with habit building.
The other thing that I want
to mention before we wrap
is that your thoughts and your
mind are built to be invisible.
So I want you to
notice your emotions
because as our thoughts
are built to be invisible,
what's not invisible
to us is how we feel.
Remember the meaning
that we're making leads
to a state experience for us.
So if you are depressed,
edit your meaning making.
Emotions come from the
meaning making that we do.
So your emotions will
always be telling you
when it's a good time to
challenge your thinking.
And so basically when you feel
crappy check your thinking.
Go back to that and edit how
you're looking at the world.
So let's wrap this up.
What we've covered.
You learned a little
bit more about me.
You learned the cost
of limiting beliefs.
We looked at core story.
We looked at the formula--
self worth equals ability
which equals performance.
We went deep into truth,
opinion, and belief.
And hopefully you now understand
meaning making in your lenses.
And you understand
this awareness shift.
This just becoming aware of
how we're making meaning,
bringing the focus
back to the lenses,
what we're doing so
that you can master
all your limiting beliefs.
You can put them down
and make other choices.
So what would
change in your life
if you'd just change one
persistent negative belief?
Probably quite a bit.
What would change in
your life if you started
being able to optimize
your thinking consistently
and on the fly?
One little change
after one little
change after one little change.
It's a whole new life.
It's a whole new way of being.
So this is a simple shift in
the evolution of consciousness.
If we're blind and just
looking through our lenses
without even knowing it,
that's a certain level
of consciousness.
And then if we develop
the awareness to do this,
it's literally a shift
in consciousness.
So raise your hand if you
learned anything useful today?
Beautiful.
Yay.
So, thank you so very
much for this time.
It's really great
to be with you.
I appreciate it.
Please stay in touch.
Home base is RobScott.com.
You can check me out
on Twitter @Rob_Scott.
And there's more on
this topic specifically
coming soon at
identityshifting.com.
And thanks for staying.
I think we're a
couple minutes over.
But if anybody
has any questions,
I'm happy to stay
for a little bit.
AUDIENCE: The people
that you worked with,
how often are they aware of
what their self limiting beliefs
are versus you sort of
helping them figure them out?
ROB SCOTT: Not very.
Not very.
They might know some and they
might have inklings of it.
But it's often not exactly
what they thought it was.
So they're not always
in our consciousness
because we're looking through
them instead of at them.
And so I have a process to
help pull that out for people
so that they can
kind of investigate
these different dimensions of
their thinking and their life.
And they often have
like a huge epiphany
of like, wow, I didn't
see that at all,
but that's been an
absolutely consistent theme
throughout my life.
And then when we
change that, there's
a huge change in their life.
Yeah.
That actually speaks a
little bit to shadow work.
Shadow is when we
kind of stuff things
psychologically down that are
not OK for our self concept.
And what ends up happening
is that we project those out
on to other people.
So we end up feeling like if
it's not OK for me to be angry,
because maybe I was born
and I was supposed to turn
the other cheek or whatever.
And now I'm in a situation as an
adult and there is anger here,
but it's not OK for me to be
angry, than someone else must
be angry.
So I actually start projecting
my anger on to other people.
And what ends up happening
is that that will actually
make someone mad.
So before you know it,
they really will be angry
and I will have proven
my little dance.
And so we go through
life like that.
What can actually happen is
you can go to therapy for 10
years working on, let's say,
anxiety because you wake up
out of dreams really,
really scared and anxious
and you're working with
a therapist on confidence
techniques and all
these different things,
but the true emotion that
needs to be addressed
is something that's
really in your shadow that
might be rage that's showing
itself in dreams of yours that
are like a big monster
that's coming at you.
And it feels like I'm
just scared of monsters,
but the reality is that nobody
else is in your dream but you,
and that rage is
you in some way.
And so it's just been
disassociated from you.
And if you don't
address that, it
doesn't really matter if
you address the other things
on top of that because that
will just keep expressing.
So digging into people's
shadow and really seeing
what the true, authentic
issue is with their psyche
is really, really important
to be able to do that.
AUDIENCE: Where do you
say the fine line is
between not being impulsive
and not falling into a routine?
ROB SCOTT: I'm not sure
I know what you mean.
So not being impulse and
not falling into a routine.
AUDIENCE: As in like
you were describing
towards the end kind of--
ROB SCOTT: Instant gratification
and delaying gratification.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But at the same
time is there a time
where you would
kind of say to lean
towards a sort of instant
gratification as long as--
ROB SCOTT: Yeah.
If you're annoyingly
anal, we're going
to need you to loosen
up and just go do
some fun stuff or something.
No, but what's
really going there
is that's obviously a personal
decision for whoever's
dealing with it.
And what we want to make sure
is that somebody to the level
that they're satisfied
in control of their life.
It's really fun to sometimes
just go do something.
But if you're
compulsively doing things
that you know are
bad for you-- I mean,
human beings are
really the only species
that I know of anyway
that consciously do
things that are bad for them.
Like we know working
out is better for us
than eating the ice cream
and we eat the ice cream.
Even though we've made a huge
declaration that we're not
going to eat the ice cream.
Even though we've
gone to a coach
and invested money
and time and effort
in not eating the ice cream.
We keep doing it.
We keep kind of choosing wrong.
And so when that's
out of control
for you, it's time
to tighten it up
I would say and work
toward mastering
delaying gratification.
I have some
shortcuts about that.
For most of us we're exhausted
with decision fatigue.
We're dealing with choices
and communication level
that we've never
had to as humans.
And so we're almost
all in a constant state
of overwhelm, shock, tiredness,
adrenal fatigue, whatever.
There's some form of that.
And so we're constantly
walking through our life
looking at all our commitments
and going, I should do that.
I should do that.
I should have all
my taxes ready.
All my emails should be zero.
That pile, my wash
should be done.
All that stuff.
And we end up at
the end of our day
feeling really bad because
we've made commitments
and we've not shown up
for ourself in any way.
And if you had a friend
that was not showing up
for dinner for you like
two or three times,
you'd not trust them, not like
them, not invite them back.
But for ourselves we continually
beat ourselves up about
how we don't show
up for ourselves.
So part of that
delaying gratification
and like figuring
that out is really
coming up with not
doing everything,
because there's just
too many invitations.
We need to start saying no to
a lot of stuff that is just
too much, choosing the
handful of things--
the three or four things--
that really, really matter
that are game changers.
You might call them
your bottom lines.
These are super important to do.
And then see if you can
play with creating behaviors
around those that really
matter to you over time.
And when you show up
like that for yourself,
making better, more clear
agreements with yourself,
you end up having this deep
sense of self, confidence,
and self love because you
are showing up for yourself.
You are getting
results, et cetera.
But when we don't
get results anywhere
because we're
overwhelmed and all that,
we start feeling
really bad and crappy
and we really do feel like
we're not enough, et cetera.
AUDIENCE: So I loved
the visualization,
but I have a quick
question on that.
Is there ever a time
in which the person
on the right who is
like very positive
where that's like
counterintuitive
and that doesn't work
as well as it should?
ROB SCOTT: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So like,
oh, I love my job
and just going above and
beyond on these statements that
may hold you back from finding
something that you really do
love.
ROB SCOTT: 100%.
And it's a really good point.
I think that in that
dramatic example
it would be good to err on
the side of positive there.
And that was really
just to illustrate
the power of showing up
kind of confident, happy,
in love with yourself.
Not egoically in
love with yourself,
but just healthily
respectful of who you are
and what you're
capable of right.
Where that really is an issue is
when you're getting delusional.
When you start to say things
like I am a millionaire.
A lot of things like The
Secret or the Law of Attraction
might kind of invite us in to.
It's got to be authentic
and it's got to be real.
And so when I help
people actually
craft those to do
the work that I do,
which we didn't go
in too deeply to,
but there's a way to like
re-pattern that for somebody's
subconscious, it really
is important in how
you pick those.
So in the amount of
time we had, it's
important to just be positive.
There's a lot of gain to that.
But then there is a way
to author those correctly
so that it's really,
really valuable for people.
And so good notice there.
AUDIENCE: In your opinion--
using the word opinion-- what
are the global implications
of the current level
of collective consciousness?
Actually I'm currently
a life coach, as well.
ROB SCOTT: Awesome.
AUDIENCE: You do what you do.
What do you think are the macro
level kind of implications
and affects-- symptoms, so
to speak-- that you have
noticed as a result of this.
ROB SCOTT: Yeah.
I think it's the
number one thing.
I think if we don't master
our own delusion-- and we can.
It's not just a hope or a wish.
It's the profound
difference in my life
and the profound
difference that I've
been able to create in
clients-- or facilitate,
I should say-- profound change.
Very, very different levels of
consciousness in these people.
Without that we're kind of
playing whack-a-mole outside.
It's like, let's
get this problem,
let's get this problem, but
we're creating more problems
and we don't kind of see it.
The story that I
often tell is I was
really interested in hearing
what Bill Gates decided
to point his philanthropy at.
Just tons of access, tons
of money, tons of ability,
access to the best
people, et cetera.
And he came up at one
point anyway with malaria
and mosquitoes.
It was like, this is the
problem we're going to solve.
And there is something that's
very awesome about that.
It's solvable.
It's a real thing.
He's going to attack it in a
way that other people haven't.
And I think he's probably
made great strides in that.
But when I hear that, I go
that's the thing that we're
working on?
That's the thing?
Because why isn't it sex
trafficking, or peak oil,
or sustainability?
Or the eight million other
things that are going on?
It's because it's not out there.
It's not out here.
Problems aren't really problems.
Problems are opportunities.
When you start to master
kind of how you think,
the whole perception of the
world really, really deeply
changes because we're not
separate from this world
perceiving this static thing.
We're creating it in
our experience of it.
So as we move to having more
healthy, really grounded
self love.
As we move to having
solutions based
thinking as a way
of being simply
because it's more useful.
Not because we're
delusional or we
want to be weirdos or
hippies or whatever,
but it's just that this
is a more useful way
to think about the world and
think about our problems,
we can elevate all
of those problems.
They start to go away.
And when you see more
conscious leaders,
whether that's political leaders
but I think there's probably
more examples of
corporate leaders,
you get really different
kinds of leadership.
You get contribution back.
You get this natural way
towards sustainability
and these problems will
start to solve themselves.
So thank you.
It's almost like you
seeded that question.
This is, I think, the
most important thing
in the whole world.
Because we are literally walking
around delusional and we're
blowing people up
for belief systems.
Our nations and our ideas only.
And we hold to them so strongly.
We actually grow 18 and 19
and 20-year-olds to go murder
other people and
be killed themself
over economies that
are made up and fake.
So we're stuck in ideas
that we're treating as true
and they're not true at all.
And we really need to
evolve how we think.
We need to really evolve how
we approach these issues.
And so if we don't
have this ability,
we're going to
remain in delusion.
It's going to be very
difficult to profoundly change
any of those things
AUDIENCE: Can you talk a little
bit about your choice of tattoo
on your hand?
ROB SCOTT: This one?
Yeah.
So that is the word "now" placed
right where a watch would go.
And it really is to signify that
time is a construct of thought.
We've never really been to
the future or into the past.
We're always here.
And there is this very
useful kind of play of time.
And so there's certainly
a reality to it.
But we're never not here.
And so this is an
invitation to be present
because if you think
about the future,
it's really anxiety and fear.
If you're thinking
about the future
it's like planning and
how am I going to win
and what's going on.
And the past is guilt and shame.
The past is like,
what did I do wrong?
What was going on back there?
And so that's what a lot
of people in our fear
based world we're
kind of living.
So the wake up to
this-- and this
is probably close
to 25 years old
now-- is just the truth
that it's always now.
We should really be
embodied and present
and in this moment fully instead
of overly anxious or worried
or carrying too much
other story, because it's
just beautiful right here.
There was a moment where I
really woke up to the fact--
like I could have been
really mad about my abusers.
I could still just be
so pissed about that.
Oh my god.
And if I do that, if I'm
experiencing about that
and ranting about it and I'm
pissed and this is horrible
and all that stuff,
what's going on?
They're not here.
Nothing's happening to me now.
Nobody's punching me or hurting
me or doing anything now.
So who's bringing it here?
I'm bringing it here.
I'm carrying this
crap from my past
and literally in the form
of experiencing it now
I'm kind of planning
it into my future just
to keep living through it
again and again and again.
And if I don't
wake up to the fact
that I'm doing that, that that's
the meaning that I'm making,
then I'm just stuck in that.
This is a very high
level group of people.
I have lived in
places where there's
a lot more dysfunction than you
might find on a Google campus.
And you see people 50-years-old
that are literally delusionally
angry about something that
happened when they were 16
and they're still mumbling
about it, carrying it around.
And the core is all in the
anger and the Pabst Blue Ribbon
to make that feel better.
That's not a very
expressed life.
That's not a powerful life.
It's not a big life.
And we're capable of more
if we can wake up and start
to manage this.
Start to manage our thinking.
ADAM: All right.
Well, thank you,
everybody for coming.
And thank you, Rob, for
sharing these ideas with us.
ROB SCOTT: Deeply
appreciate your time.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you.
Awesome.